ja die aktuellen corona zahlen in dieser
krise ist es doch entscheiden diese
zahlen zu kennen denn anhand dieser
zahlen muss die regierung dann die
korona regeln beschließen aber unsere
regierung die kennt die wahren corona
zahlen derzeit nicht wie viele menschen
infizieren sich eigentlich gerade wo und
wie schlimm erkranken sie und wie viele
davon mit der omicron variante andere
länder haben diese informationen bei uns
in deutschland aber sieht das so aus ja
das ist das robert-koch-institut sie
haben gerade schon gesehen diesen
hinweis auf der website war es mal
wieder dort warnt dass es eben nur ein
unvollständiges bild der lage gibt wie
vor einem jahr immer noch also die
regierung kennt immer noch die wahren
corona zahlen nichts ja und das wird
sich leider auch erst mal nicht ändern
frühestens in der zweiten januarwoche
werde es wieder genaue zahlen geben sagt
das so wird koch institut das heißt
deutschland ist noch mindestens zehn
tage lang im koma zahlen blind für ein
wahnsinn die regierung kennt die zahlen
sich das ist auch für uns alle diesen
problemen denn schon am 17 januar wollen
regierung und ministerpräsidenten die
neuen corona regeln beschließen obwohl
auch dann noch niemand die wahren zahlen
kennt das ist frustrierend und es ist
ehrlich gesagt auch nicht mehr zu
erklären
vor allem auch weil andere länder diese
waren zahlen ja auch haben schauen sie
mal hier wie das in großbritannien zum
beispiel aussieht da gibt es aktuell
diese kurven mit drin natürlich alle
aktuellen omikron fälle also halten wir
fest so geht's auch ja deutschland
dagegen muss der gesundheitsminister
gerade die zahlen schätzen sandra karl
lauterbach sagt die inzidenz könnt so
zwei drei mal höher liegen als derzeit
angegeben also wie gesagt das ist eine
schätzung das muss man sich mal geben
der bundesregierung unsere regierung die
die waren corinna zahlen weiterhin nicht
kennt darüber sprechen wir jetzt mit dem
biologen professor klaus stöhr der uns
zugeschaltet ist schönen guten tag schon
gut morgen unter meinung ist dass der
unlösbare aufgabe nach über zwei jahren
corona krise verlässliche corona zahlen
zu liefern ja es gibt ja einige länder
die beweisen dass das keine unlösbare
aufgabe ist dieses diese daten wüste hat
zwei komponenten der eine ist die der
aktuellen zahlen das hat deutschland
natürlich auch nur gewisse
schwierigkeiten zu überwinden die daten
liegt bei den ländern und wider von
realismus ist hier eigentlich nicht sehr
hilfreich das drk erhält da die daten
aber man hätte sicherlich schon vor
einigen jahren und jahrzehnten sich
überlegen können wie schafft man das in
krisen dort nun auch ein zuverlässiges
datenbeschaffung analyse und dann auch
bewertungssystem zu etablieren also das
hat man beschlagnahme der zweite teil
dieser daten wüste ist aus meiner sicht
noch viel schlimmer nämlich es gibt kein
bewertungssystem die maßnahmen
analysiert zu ihrer effizienz wie
wirksam ist die quarantäne wieviel fälle
kann man mit kontakt nachverfolgung auch
verhindern wie gut ist ist die
grenzschließungen bei der bei der
reduktion der einstieg und dann gibt es
eine lange liste von begleitenden
wissenschaftlichen untersuchungen die
man von anfang an hätte etablieren
müssen um zu wissen wo an welcher stelle
der effizienz man sich bewegt und das
ist meines erachtens sogar noch mehr
schwieriger und schlechtere teil und
dann liegt england jetzt wieder neue
daten vorgelegt man zur uni kann und
selbst südafrika mit seinen tollen
publikation
den auswirkungen von omikron bekanntes
stück vor deutschland aber hersteller
lassen sie uns mal ganz schön auf den
ersten teil auch schauen sie haben
gesagt die daten werden nicht wichtig
übermittelt oder nicht so so häufig
übermittelt na klar ist es gerade
weihnachtspause zwischen den jahren der
arbeiten viele menschen nicht fahren
halt gerne im urlaub aber müsste man
nicht sagen wirklich in der pandemie
gibt es kein urlaub da muss jeder
arbeiten wir arbeiten auch alle wir
wollen helfen wir wollen das weiter
entwickeln wir wollen die richtigen
zahlen haben woran hat
dafür muss man langfristig vorbereiten
das ist ja wie offene intensivstation
oder wie bei der s-bahn in berlin ihr
plant man lange voraus und überlegt
nicht wie man unseren solchen
bedingungen dann auch den betrieb am
laufen hält und das bedeutet
krisen-management langfristigen
vorbereitung auch interaktionen die
nicht unbedingt auf gesetzlicher
grundlage auf folgendes ja auch
schwierig wie gesagt in den föderalismus
diese daten dann auch zuverlässig
einzufordern aber das muss man vorher
eben durch kollaborationen durch
anbieten von lösungen durch gemeinsame
vorbereitung überwinden und das ist
offensichtlich nicht erfolgt das lka hat
natürlich da auch ein super schweren
stand alles die institution schieben das
ist eben die bundesregierung und das
bundesgesundheitsministerium dass ich
hätte man sich auch noch etwas
vorbereiten müssen in anderen ländern
hat man andere möglichkeiten aber auch
andere planung und krisen management
optionen ausgewählt ja auch weil man die
erfahrung aus dem vergangenen jahr schon
hatte weihnachten kam diesmal ja nicht
ganz so überraschend ehrlicherweise str
wie ist das jetzt mit dieser schätzung
von bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach der sagte heute über daumen
gepeilt sage ich jetzt mal die inzidenz
müsste so zwei bis dreimal höher liegen
als derzeit angegeben er hat dazu
natürlich daten mit seinem hinterkopf
vergleichswerte aus dem ausland aus dem
benachbarten länder dabei wie seriös ist
es dann so eine schätzung anzugeben
ja ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen wenn ich
hier mit dem auto fahren und ich war der
tag frankreich gleich noch verhandelt
kilometer unter 100 kilometer dann ist
das schon ein signifikanter unterschied
also das sollte man solche sachen sollte
man tunlichst vermeiden in dieser
größenordnung nicht prozent unterschied
hierbei aber lassen sie mich noch mal
zurückkommen auf die frage was müsste
man jetzt eigentlich unternehmen worauf
müsste man sich vorbereiten und das ist
die frage wie schlimm könnte es nach
silvester kommen die omikron variante
wird nicht weiter ausbreiten was
vergessen würdest das immer seltener
fall auch weg stellt für einen unfall
und diese daten denn eigentlich
entscheiden wird die inzidenz gar nicht
so wichtig jetzt müsste man wissen wie
viel fälle nikon
erkrankter kommen dann ins krankenhaus
nicht von denen brauchen eine
ventilation wer von den müssen auf die
eu und wäre von denen werden sterben und
die zahlen liegen aus südafrika vor die
linke auch aus der england vor die kann
man sicherlich partiell in großem umfang
auch extrapolieren auf deutschland und
jetzt müsste man sich vorbereiten was
man macht dann im januar und da glaube
ich liegt der größte
mangel denen ich sehe jetzt müssen die
daten genutzt werden aus dem ausland
exportierten aus deutschland und dann
muss man nicht überlegen es hat eine
ungefähr 4 fache erhöhung der fälle
geben durch um die konnte im vergleich
der delta aber es gibt nur ein viertel
so viel
krankenhauseinweisung also die
krankenhauseinweisungen insgesamt wären
höchst wahrscheinlich auf demselben
niveau bleiben aber aus südafrika oder
england die zahlen die zeigen dass 70
prozent derjenigen die ausstehenden die
stationen kommen eine leichte und oder
die krankenhaus kommen so was richtig
leichteren verlauf nahmen kein ob sie
keinen sauerstoff brauchen nicht in die
eu müssen wurde die sterbefälle auf den
also auf diese veränderte situation
leider nicht mit auf der grundlage runde
aus deutschland sondern aus dem ausland
muss man sich jetzt vorbereiten und die
maßnahme dann auch entsprechend
vorbereiten dass ihr umgesetzt werden
kann dass man nicht wieder die noten
rausholt wie das panik orchester und
dann wie bei alpha und beta sondern dass
man real auf der evidenz basierend auch
handeln kann aber wir brauchen die
zahlen natürlich schnellstmöglich denn
am 17 januar findet ja schon die nächste
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz statt da
werden dann neue maßnahmen beschlossen
vielleicht verschärfungen vielleicht
aber auch entlastungen aufgrund dann
falscher oder nicht aussagekräftiger
zahlen wie kann das sein
ja es ist ja nicht so ungewöhnlich dass
einige maßnahmen auf schwacher daten
basis erfolgt sind die gutachten
erstellt wurden in deutschland für das
bundesverfassungsgericht die
wissenschaftlichen als die evaluiert
haben ob die interventionen
gerechtfertigt war nur nicht waren alles
analog schluss es gibt aus deutschland
der wenige daten die zeigen wie die den
sogenannten non formation intervention
also kontakt beschränkung und so weiter
auch wirken und so lange man die
begleitenden wissenschaftlichen
untersuchungen verbindet mit den akten
nicht verbinden kann mit den aktuellen
daten sowie das jetzt über weihnachten
silvester passiert ist es natürlich
unheimlich schwer
verhältnismäßige maßnahmen umsetzen und
hinterher zu bewerten ob sie dann auch
irgendeine wirkung haben also es gibt
doch jetzt in deutschland sowie keine
daten die belegen wie wirksam ist in die
quarantäne wieviel fälle kann man
verhindern mit einer kontakt
beschränkung also das sind ja auch alles
wichtige dinge wenn jetzt die politiker
sagen wir wollen und aktenschränke und
wir wollen wieder quandt jene verkürzen
oder verlängern ja wir sind teller haben
wir denn dann verhindern ist das jedoch
nur zwei bis dreifach mal soviel
ungefähr oder ist eine emotionale frage
oder können wir das auch staaten gründen
da glaube ich ist ist eigentlich der
wichtigste teil den man in deutschland
wirklich über vier jahre gleich
vergessen hat mit dem biologischen
forschung begleiten für die intervention
das würde jedes unternehmen anders
machen das muss auch jede regierung kann
das machen so kann man nicht nur ein
unternehmen nicht führen sondern
eigentlich auch ein land nicht vielen
dank an den virologen klatschte heute
bei bild live die regierung die nach wie
vor die wahren corona zahlen nicht kennt
das ist weiter thema hier weil uns bei
bild live und darüber wollen wir auch
sprechen jetzt mit bayerns fdp- chef
martin hagen schönen guten tag herr
hagen die regierung kennt die wahren
corona zahlen immer noch nicht letztes
jahr lief schon genauso dieses jahr
wieder so möglicherweise erst in zehn
tagen haben wir wieder realistische
zahlen auf dem schreibtisch wer
verantwortet dass die laster
das ist in den letzten zwei jahren in
der verantwortung von bund und ländern
gewesen wir haben auf die seiten der
bundesebene erlebt dass offenbar die
datenbasis für nicht so relevant
gefunden wurde dass man alles getan hat
um hier eine ordentliche erfassung
verarbeitung der zahlen hinzubekommen
wir haben drastische grundrechts
einschränkungen erlebt bis hin zum
lockdown mit ausgangssperren und
schulschließungen und das auf einer
datenbasis die dafür total ungeeignet
ist und ich fürchte dass wir das jetzt
bei der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
wieder erleben ich halte den zeitpunkt
sind der januar für die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz für total
ungeeignet denn bevor wir ein
realistisches bild der lage haben bevor
diese melde verfüge über die feiertage
abgearbeitet sind kann eine
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz eigentlich
nichts beschließen aber die jetzt noch
mehr zu verzögern wer natürlich auch das
falsche signal man hätte einfach jetzt
auch zwischen den jahren auch während
weihnachten natürlich viel mehr arbeiten
müssen oder was ist ihre meinung ja
natürlich wir sind in einer
existenziellen krise und trotzdem macht
der öffentliche gesundheitsdienst nach
wie vor weihnachtsferien das war letztes
jahr schon da fallen wir haben jetzt ja
ja dramatisch steigende zahlen über die
feiertage gab das hat sich dann alles
erst im januar abgebildet in den
offiziellen zahlen das zeigt natürlich
dass die prioritätensetzung ihr komplett
falsch ist das liegt aber nicht an den
menschen die in den gesundheitsämtern
arbeiten die machen ja nur den job den
man ihn aufgibt sondern das liegt an der
man in person ausstattung und das liegt
natürlich auch daran dass die
gesundheitsämter immer noch häufig nicht
auf einem angemessenen stand der
digitalisierung sind das bundesweite
system sommers das ja eine zentrale
schnittstelle für diese daten sein soll
das wird jedenfalls in bayern immer noch
in fast der hälfte der gesundheitsämter
nicht angewendet und das zeigt natürlich
wo hier die defizite liegen wir arbeiten
im öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst immer
noch mit methoden der 90er jahre aber
das tolle ist ja sie können es jetzt mit
aufräumen in der bundesregierung herr
hagen ihre minister sie sind jetzt da
zuständig für die digitalisierung sie
stellt zwar nicht den
gesundheitsminister sie stellt aber den
digital minister sie stellen auch falls
es irgendwelche rechtlichen probleme
gibt den justizminister sie stellen auch
noch falls es am geld scheitern den
finanzminister als sie können richtig
aufräumen bis wann haben sie das mit dem
rest der regierung beseitigt dieses
daten desaster
es wird in dieser regierung nicht am
geld scheitern und ich freue mich dass
die bundesregierung die neue haben wir
jetzt auch schon als eine der ersten
amtshandlung beschlossen hat dass
endlich mal valide zahlen auf den tisch
kommen zur frage wie viele geimpfte wie
viele ungeimpfte liegenden auf den
intensivstationen es ist ja ein unding
dass das zwei jahre dauert bis man mal
so eine übersicht dann überhaupt
erstellen dass diese zahlen kommen jetzt
auch im januar also ich denke das wird
die neue bundesregierung mit karl
lauterbach als gesundheitsminister und
der fdp die ihr um das ressort
digitalisierung sich kümmert sehr sehr
schnell angehen und das ist auch
entscheidend denn gute politische
entscheidungen kann man nur treffen auf
basis guter daten und diese daten fehlen
uns komplett fehlen uns zum beispiel
auch in bayern wir haben hier erst
jüngst die affäre gehabt dass das
landesamt für gesundheit völlig falsche
incidents zahlen herausgegeben hat zur
frage wie verteilen sich die instanzen
auf geimpften und ungeimpften auf basis
dieser völlig falschen zahlen werden
dann maßnahmen wie zweig oder auch die
diskussion um eine impfpflicht geführt
und wenn wir als opposition sagen wir
wollen die echten zahlen haben mauert
die regierung wir haben diese zahlen bis
heute nicht wir werden im zweifel vor
das verfassungsgericht ziehen damit
markus söders behörde endlich die zahlen
ausdrückt das ist die kritik an bayern
noch einmal ganz kurz nachgefragt weil
das meine frage war er hagen bis wann
muss dieses datendesaster aufgelöst sein
bis wann müssen wir verlässliche zahlen
haben
im grunde muss das innerhalb weniger
wochen passieren aber sie müssen auch
das natürlich personal und digitale
infrastruktur in behörden sich nicht von
heute auf morgen direkt verbessern
lassen aber das muss eine priorität sein
für die bundesregierung ich finde es
inakzeptabel wenn auf basis von so
unsicheren daten jetzt neue maßnahmen
beschlossen werden gerne die mpk eine
woche nach hinten verschieben und bis
dahin alles tun damit die echten zahlen
auf dem tisch liegen damit man auf einer
soliden grundlage aber soliden daten
grundlage dann auch wirksame
entscheidungen treffen kann wir brauchen
endlich wirksame maßnahmen um dieser
pandemie hat zu werden und nicht immer
diese aktionistischen aktionen die die
freiheit der bürger einschränken aber
gegen das virus tatsächlich oft sehr
wenig ausrichten heran was sie
allerdings hier und heute versprechen
könnten und auch müssten ist dass das
chaos zumindest im nächsten winter also
nächstes jahr ausbleibt können sie das
ich kann nicht für die bundesregierung
sprechen weil ich ja nicht angehöre aber
ich kann ihnen versprechen dass das bei
karl lauterbach in guten händen ist und
dass das auch bei volker wissing unserem
digital minister in guten händen ist
also für die fdp kann ich sagen ist das
eine absolute priorität wir dürfen
nächstes jahr nicht noch einmal so ein
desaster erleben ist dieses jahr der
fall war und da wird die bundesregierung
auf alles zu tun was in ihrer macht
steht das hängt aber natürlich auch
immer wieder an den landesregierung das
ist im föderalismus so bund und land
müssen hand in hand arbeiten
und ich hoffe dass das auch in bayern
verstanden wird sie machen politik in
bayern herr hagen herzlichen dank für
das gespräch mit ihnen